so you want a PS5 huh well PlayStation
boss Jim Ryan delivered some fantastic
news at CES 2023 this week and said
quote you should have a much easier time
finding one at retailers globally
starting from this point forward this is
also pretty good news for those of you
that want to buy your second or third
PS5
I'll see you you greedy little Tech
hoarders the PS5 launched in November
2020 and it quickly became very
difficult to find I am still completely
shocked I managed to find one at Walmart
that December this lack of availability
was due in part to the global
semiconductor shortage as well as other
supply chain and Logistics issues and
for what it's worth Microsoft had Xbox
shortage issues too as did Nintendo with
the switch to an extent no one was safe
Sony also confirmed that CES that the
PS5 has now reached 30 million units
sold globally December 2022 was the
ps5's biggest month of all time sales
even surpassing the console's launch
month so now that there are more ps5s
making their way downtown walking fast
does that mean we're gonna finally see a
new model well there continue to be
rumors of a Slimmer PS5 model but
nothing has been confirmed as of yet I'm
just terrified of a possible pro model I
don't think my TV stand can handle that
however when it comes to new hardware
Sony did announce project Leonardo a
customizable accessibility controller
kit for the PlayStation 5. project
Leonardo features a circular base and a
kit of swappable buttons and joysticks
that can be fully customized to the
player's specific needs unfortunately no
official release information or a price
were mentioned in the blog post or on
stage at CES only that the controller is
still currently in development and
speaking of things being worked on
vampire survivors developer ponco has
announced more updates are coming but
they'll be releasing at a slower Pace
from the sound of the post it seems that
panko has been quite overwhelmed with
porting vampire survivors to consoles
and Mobile in addition to releasing the
legacy of the moonspell DLC punkle even
says in the post that the DLC ended up
having quite a bit more content than
originally planned but that the
developer is still working on bringing
it to mobile as far as future updates
are concerned panko says that though
paid DLC will add more characters
weapons and stages to the game the main
game will still receive substantial
updates in mechanics and content in 2023
the developer hopes to find a more
sustainable pipeline for patches because
they now have to maintain both the
mobile and PC slash console versions of
the game there must be an insane amount
of pressure when you're a small team
working on a game that becomes Uber
popular in such a small amount of time
and to be fair it's tough to live up to
expectations for development teams both
big and small which is something that
Bluebird team is finding out as they
work on the Silent Hill 2 remake in an
interview with Dread XP Bloomer team's
marketing Chief Anna jazinska said quote
the pressure is high since we're dealing
with one of the best psychological
horror games ever made we want to stick
close to the original and we will put it
in the spotlight for years to come
jazinska also said Bluebird is taking a
very safe approach to any changes but it
would consider adjustments that would
improve the overall game experience for
modern players this sounds wonderful if
peeing your pants to scary games is your
type of thing seriously why why do you
like scary things I still don't get it
I've asked a bunch of times you know the
audience people close to me why I don't
why why